This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Everything outside might be frightful, but a new batch of mini-stories are here to make the next 30 minutes or so absolutely delightful. So grab something warm, gather the kids around the old wireless transceiver, and enjoy stories about funny and surprisingly controversial highway signs, Jane Fonda saving you money on rent. The most famous act of contrition of all time, or possibly the greatest PR comeback of all time, depending
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。外面或许寒风凛冽，但我们准备了一批全新的迷你故事，让你的接下来的30分钟左右变得无比美妙。所以，拿上一杯热饮，把孩子们聚在旧收音机旁，一起来听听关于那些有趣且出人意料地引发争议的高速公路标语的故事，简·方达帮你节省房租的故事，史上最著名的忏悔行为，或者也有可能是史上最厉害的公关卷土重来的故事，具体取决于
on who you're asking. And we learned together that the most accomplished artists of the classical world have all agreed that I, your host, have the most beautiful feet that a person can have. Let's go. person can have. Let's go. So I'm joined by a producer, Chris Berube. Hey, Chris. Roman, it is the most wonderful time of the year. Uh, great to be here. It's a delight to have you. So what is the story you have for us today? So Roman, I know I'm always comparing America to Canada as resident Canadian guy on the show. Yes, I'm well aware. Yeah.
你问的是谁。而且我们一起了解到，古典世界中最杰出的艺术家们都一致认为，我，你们的主持人，拥有一个人所能拥有的最美丽的双脚。我们开始吧。一个人所能拥有的最美丽的双脚。我们开始吧。所以和我一起的是制作人克里斯·贝尔伯。嗨，克里斯。罗曼，这是一年中最好的时光。呃，很高兴来到这里。很高兴你能来。那么你今天给我们带来了什么故事呢？罗曼，我知道作为节目中的常驻加拿大人，我总是把美国和加拿大作对比。是的，我很清楚。是的。
Look, my New Year's resolution, I'm going to tone down the Canada stuff for next year on the show. Yes, I'm well aware. Look, my New Year's resolution, I'm gonna tone down the Canada stuff for next year on the show. I don't think you have to, but you do what feels right to you. Okay, okay. But I feel like I'm always making these comparisons that are like, this is better in Canada,
听着，我的新年决心是，明年在节目中我要收敛一下加拿大的事情。是的，我很清楚。听着，我的新年决心是，明年在节目中我要收敛一下加拿大的事情。我觉得你没必要这样，但你做自己觉得对的事就行。好的，好的。但我觉得我总是做这样的对比，比如，在加拿大这更好，
this is better in Canada. One thing I do prefer in America is the electronic highway safety sign. Like a light board and it has text on it. And it's a thing that will say like left lane closed ahead, something like that, right? Got it, got it, got it. Okay, so why do you like the ones in the US better?
在加拿大这更好。我更喜欢美国的一点是电子高速公路安全标语。就像一个发光板，上面有文字。它会显示比如前方左侧车道封闭之类的内容，对吧？明白了，明白了，明白了。好吧，那你为什么更喜欢美国的呢？
In Canada, the signs are always bland, right? They will say something like, don't drive drunk. And then it will also say that same thing in French, right? But to express the same message in the US, I have found there are often jokes. So let me give you an example. Pennsylvania recently, they had a highway sign around the 4th of July that read, don't drive star-spangled hammered.
在加拿大，标语总是很平淡，对吧？它们会说类似“请勿酒后驾驶”之类的话。然后还会用法语再说一遍，对吧？但要在美国表达同样的意思，我发现通常会有笑话。所以让我举个例子。宾夕法尼亚州最近在7月4日前后有一个高速公路标语，上面写着：别开星条旗醉车。
Okay, here I can give you some other ones. These are all over the country. So in Mississippi, they ran a sign this year that said, four eyes in Mississippi, two eyes on the road. That's pretty good. In Massachusetts, it's use ya blinka. I like this one in New Jersey, they have one that said, slow down, this ain't Thunder Road.
好吧，这里我可以给你举一些其他的。这些标语全国到处都是。比如在密西西比州，他们今年推出了一个标语，上面写着：密西西比有四只眼，盯着路只要两只眼。这挺不错的。在马萨诸塞州，标语是“用你的转向灯吧”。我喜欢新泽西州的这个，他们有一个标语写着：慢点开，这不是“雷霆路”。
So a joke for the Springsteen dads. And this phenomenon, it's actually across the country. So Roman, have you actually seen any of these? I don't think, these are very prominent in California, but I'm enjoying these are very prominent in California, but I'm enjoying these quite a bit. Yeah, they're fun. So I was curious about these and it turns out
所以这是一个针对斯普林斯廷老爹们的梗。这种现象其实全国各地都有。罗曼，你实际上见过这些标语吗？我不认为，这些在加州非常醒目，但我挺喜欢这些的，非常醒目，但我挺喜欢这些的。是的，它们很有趣。所以我对这些很好奇，结果发现
it's a very involved process to put these up. I would imagine so. So tell me more. I actually found this out because I talked to somebody who writes these signs. My name is Matt Burding. I'm the press secretary at the Ohio Department of Transportation.
把这些标语竖起来是一个非常复杂的流程。我能想象得到。所以多跟我讲讲。我其实是因为跟一个写这些标语的人聊过，才发现这一点的。我叫马特·伯丁。我是俄亥俄州交通局的新闻秘书。
What ODOT does is make sure that the snow is cleared in the wintertime, make sure that the roads are passable in the summertime. We also have a big role to play in safety projects across the state. Oh, wow. He has the modulation of an AM radio broadcaster. He's a good voice. Yeah, actually, he was a radio broadcaster for many years before he was at the Ohio Department of Transportation.
俄亥俄州交通局做的工作是确保冬天积雪被清扫干净，确保夏天道路通畅。我们在全州的交通安全项目中也扮演着重要角色。哦，哇。他的语调真像个AM广播播音员。他的声音很好听。对，其实在加入俄亥俄州交通局之前，他当了好多年的广播播音员。
So that's why. That makes sense. Wow. So Matt works at ODOT, Ohio Department of Transportation, and they have about 200 of these electronic highway signs. And Matt says their primary goal, it's to convey emergency information or information like left lane closed ahead, right? But most of the time they don't have messages like this they need to share so they have all of this free space on the signs. And Matt says a couple years ago ODOT started playing around with the funny signs and they kept doing it because according to Matt they just make a much bigger impact.
难怪。这就说得通了。哇。所以马特在俄亥俄州交通局工作，他们大约有200个这样的电子高速公路标语。马特说他们的主要目标是传达紧急信息，或者像“前方左侧车道封闭”这样的信息，对吧？但大多数时候他们没有需要分享的这类消息，所以标语上就有所有这些空白空间。马特说几年前俄亥俄州交通局开始尝试搞笑标语，他们一直坚持这样做，因为据马特说，这些标语能产生大得多的影响。
Think about the Super Bowl and you watch the ads during the Super Bowl. Which ads are you most likely talking about Monday morning? You're talking about the ones that made you laugh or the ones that made you have an emotional reaction. I mean, that certainly makes sense to me. So where do these specific jokes come from? Like who writes the jokes? So Robin in Ohio where Matt works, they actually have a writer's room coming up with these
想想超级碗，你在超级碗期间看广告。星期一早上你最有可能讨论的是哪些广告？你讨论的是那些让你发笑的广告，或者那些让你产生情感共鸣的广告。我的意思是，这对我来说当然说得通。那么这些特定的笑话是从哪里来的呢？比如是谁写的这些笑话？罗曼，在马特工作的俄亥俄州，他们实际上有一个编剧室来构思这些
jokes. Of course. That's great. So four times a year, they have a writer's room coming up with these jokes. Of course, that's great. So four times a year they have a meeting, everybody comes to this meeting with like a list of ideas, they debate them and then they set a lot of couple that are going to end up on the signs. I mean, sometimes I'll bring, you know, a couple dozen ideas and 30% of them don't fly. And sometimes you bring, you know, just a handful of them and they all go. So it just varies.
笑话。当然。太棒了。所以一年四次，他们会有一个编剧室来构思这些笑话。当然，太棒了。所以一年有四次会议，每个人都带着一堆点子来开会，他们进行辩论，然后选定许多最终会出现在标语上的点子。我的意思是，有时我会带，你知道，几十个点子，其中30%通不过。有时你带，你知道，只有几个点子，它们就全都通过了。所以这很不固定。
Yeah, that sounds like every pitch room I've ever been in. I mean, 30% is a pretty good failure rate, honestly. I was going to say, yeah, if our pitch meetings went that well, I think we'd be having a really good pitch meeting. But according to Matt, they're coming up with these jokes and there's a couple of parameters they have to work with. So obviously, first thing, it has to fit on the sign, right? But according to Matt, they're coming up with these jokes and there's a couple of parameters they have to work with so Obviously first thing it has to fit on the sign, right? Right in Ohio Most of the signs are about 17 characters across three lines. So that's not nothing but that's not an unlimited amount of space
是的，听起来就像我经历过的每一个提案会议。我的意思是，30%的失败率其实已经算相当不错了。我正想说，是的，如果我们提案会议能进展得这么顺利，我觉得我们的提案会议就会开得非常成功。但据马特所说，他们在构思这些笑话时，有一些必须遵守的参数。所以很明显，第一件事，它必须能写进标语里，对吧？但据马特所说，他们在构思这些笑话时，有一些必须遵守的参数，所以很明显，第一件事，它必须能写进标语里，对吧？没错。在俄亥俄州，大多数标语分三行，每行大约17个字符。所以这虽然不是什么都没有，但也并不是有无限的空间。
So first thing it has to fit on the sign. Mm-hmm. It also obviously shouldn't be offensive shouldn't hurt anybody's feelings things like that But above all it has to make everybody in the room laugh. Yeah, which is probably the hardest criterion of all, because humor is subjective, you know? Of course, yeah. And Matt says part of how they correct for that is they always try to make sure they have people from different generations at each meeting.
所以第一件事是它必须适合标语。嗯嗯。显然它也不应该具有冒犯性，不应该伤害任何人的感情诸如此类。但最重要的是，它必须让房间里的每个人都大笑。是的，这可能是所有标准中最难的一个，因为幽默是主观的，你知道的？当然，是的。马特说他们纠正这一点的方法之一是，他们总是努力确保每次会议都有不同年代的人参加。
So he says they always make sure there's like a Gen Z staff person in there, there's a Gen Xer, you know, and if everybody's laughing, then it's probably going to work with the general public. There has to be someone there to tell you what cap means. Exactly. That's super smart. So what kind of jokes work for that whole room?
所以他说他们总是确保里面有一个Z世代的员工，有一个X世代的员工，你知道，如果每个人都在笑，那么它很可能也会对普通公众奏效。得有人在那儿告诉你“cap”是什么意思。没错。这太聪明了。那么什么样的笑话适合整个房间呢？
Matt told me there's a couple of subjects that always tend to work pretty well. So the first one is holidays. So a couple of years ago, ODOT had this sign for the holiday season. It was visiting in-laws, slow down, get there late. Solid. One of them, for example, around Thanksgiving that we run every year is Turkey Says Buckle Buckle. It's goofy. It's one of those things that I can certainly hear a dad saying as he's driving with his family to grandma's house for Thanksgiving dinner. And the kids are all probably rolling their eyes going,
马特告诉我，有几个主题往往效果一直挺好。所以第一个是节日。所以几年前，俄亥俄州交通局在节日期间推出了这个标语。拜访岳父母，慢点开，晚点到。很扎实。其中一个例子，比如我们每年感恩节都会推出的，是“火鸡说：系好安全带”。这很滑稽。这是那种我绝对能听到一位父亲在开车带家人去奶奶家吃感恩节晚餐时会说的话。孩子们可能都在翻白眼，心想：
great dad, awful joke. Yeah, it's on the sign. You guys are all buckled up, right? Second inspiration is local references. So you'll make a joke about a football game coming up. Be like, you know, don't be like Michigan, drive defensively. I don't know, I'm just making up an example.
好啦老爸，真是个烂笑话。是的，标语上就写着呢。你们都系好安全带了吧？第二个灵感是本地梗。所以你会拿即将到来的一场橄榄球比赛开个玩笑。比如，“别像密歇根队那样，防守要做好。”我不知道，我只是随口编个例子。
I don't know if Michigan's football team is bad at defense, but you'll make some joke about a geography pun, right? A lot of states do this. And Matt says the ODOT team actually will steal signs from other states and then just update them with their own local references. I'm going to be honest with you. Look, we all talk to each other.
我不知道密歇根橄榄球队的防守是不是很差，但你会拿地理双关语开个玩笑，对吧？很多州都这么做。马特说，俄亥俄州交通局的团队实际上会“借鉴”其他州的点子，然后用他们自己的本地梗来更新。说实话。听着，我们大家都是互相交流的。
So, you know, what's a good idea in Colorado is probably a good idea in Ohio too. I don't remember which state it was. I want to say maybe it was Utah that did camp in the mountains, not the left lane. We don't really have mountains in Ohio, but we did camp in Ohio State parks, not the left lane. I think Missouri does camp in the Ozarks, not the left lane. Matt says this is like part of the process is that states loves to steal from each other and like they'll meet up at a conference and they'll trade these jokes and be like,
所以，你知道，科罗拉多州的一个好点子在俄亥俄州也大概是个好点子。我不记得是哪个州了。我想说可能是犹他州，他们的标语是“在山里露营，别在左侧车道”。俄亥俄州其实没什么山，但我们的是“在俄亥俄州立公园露营，别在左侧车道”。我想密苏里州的是“在欧扎克山脉露营，别在左侧车道”。马特说这是流程的一部分，各个州很喜欢互相借鉴，他们会在会议上碰面，然后交换这些笑话，心想：
oh, that works, I could do this for mine. So you got geography, you got holidays. The signs that get the most attention though, these are the ones in Ohio and across America that everybody seems to love. They are inspired by pop culture. So these are the signs that go viral. These are the signs people are posting on social media.
哦，那个管用，我也可以在我的标语上用这个。所以你有地理梗，有节日梗。不过获得最多关注的标语，是俄亥俄州以及全美各地每个人似乎都喜爱的那些。它们的灵感来源于流行文化。所以这些就是会走红的标语。这些是人们发到社交媒体上的标语。
Roman, could I share a couple of the pop culture jokes? I would be disappointed if you did not. Okay, so here we go. Arizona, they ran this one around Christmas a couple of years ago. Yippee-ki-yay, sober drivers. Oh my God, okay. So that's of course a diehard reference.
罗曼，我能分享几个流行文化梗吗？如果你不分享的话我会很失望的。好的，那我们开始吧。亚利桑那州，他们在几年前的圣诞节前后用了这个标语。新年快乐，清醒的司机们。哦天哪，好吧。所以这当然是个《虎胆龙威》的梗。
Yeah, of course, the ultimate Christmas movie, yeah. More recently, Mississippi ran one that said, texting and driving, say, hi, it's me. I'm the problem, it's me. I mean, it's a simple one, but you know, Taylor Swift was really big that summer, that makes sense. Yeah. And pop culture jokes are great because, you know,
对，当然，终极圣诞电影，对吧。最近一点，密西西比州有一个标语写着：开车发短信，说：嗨，是我。我才是那个问题人物，是我。我的意思是，这是一个简单的梗，但你知道，泰勒·斯威夫特那个夏天真的很火，这说得通。是的。而且流行文化梗很棒，因为，你知道，
they're more relevant than your kind of dad jokey, turkey gobble gobble jokes, but it's kind of high risk too, right? Because not everybody is going to get the joke necessarily. Yeah, no, that makes sense to me. We don't all consume the same pop culture, especially today. Yeah.
它们比你的那种老爸笑话式的“火鸡咯咯叫”梗更具时效性，但这也是有一定风险的，对吧？因为不一定每个人都能get到这个梗。是的，不，这对我来说说得通。我们并不是都消费相同的流行文化，尤其是今天。是的。
Right. And that can be really alienating, right? So Matt actually has a perfect example of this, where they tried a pop culture one and it just went wrong. Being in Ohio, if you know the movie, A Christmas Story, very popular in Ohio because it was filmed in the Cleveland area. So one year we put on the message boards, life is fragile, slow down. And we spelled out phonetically fragile because if you're familiar with The Christmas Story, you know the scene where the dad opens up the, you know, gets the box of the big prize that he wins and, you know, Fragile must be Italian.
没错。那可能会非常有疏离感，对吧？所以马特实际上有一个很好的例子，他们尝试了一个流行文化梗，结果却翻车了。身处俄亥俄州，如果你知道电影《圣诞故事》，它在俄亥俄州非常受欢迎，因为它是在克利夫兰地区拍摄的。所以有一年我们在信息板上写道：生活很脆弱，请慢点开。我们用拼读法拼出了“脆弱”，因为如果你熟悉《圣诞故事》，你就会知道那个场景：父亲打开，你知道，拿到了他赢得的大奖的盒子，然后，你知道，“‘脆弱’（Fragile）一定是个意大利语”。
There are people who have not seen a Christmas story, believe it or not, who read that and were like, what in the world is ODOT trying to say here? You're driving on the highway at 70 miles an hour. We can't explain it to you. You just got to get it. And if you don't get it, then that's probably not a good message to run.
信不信由你，有些人没看过《圣诞故事》，他们读到这个标语时会想：俄亥俄州交通局这到底想表达什么？你在高速公路上以每小时70英里的速度开车。我们没法向你解释。你懂就懂。如果你不懂，那这可能就不是一个适合发布的标语。
So in general, people love these signs. You know, they're popular, they get shared on social media, but there is a problem. One group in particular really does not like them. And that group is the Federal Highway Administration. Oh no, those guys. Those guys. Well, the FHWA, they're in charge of highway safety
所以总的来说，人们很喜欢这些标语。你知道，它们很受欢迎，在社交媒体上被转发，但也有一个问题。其中有一个群体非常不喜欢它们。那个群体就是联邦公路管理局。哦不，又是那帮家伙。那帮家伙。嗯，联邦公路管理局，他们负责美国的公路安全，
for the United States, and in their opinion these signs can be kind of a distraction. So a couple years ago, they actually made New Jersey take down one of these signs. So the sign said, hold on to your butts, help prevent forest fires. Ha ha ha, funny joke. But what happened is people were actually slowing down to take pictures of the sign, which is obviously not safe. It's kind of working at cross purposes to what the sign is supposed to be doing.
在他们看来，这些标语可能会分散注意力。所以几年前，他们实际上让新泽西州撤下了其中一个标语。所以那个标语写着：抓紧你们的屁股，帮助防止森林火灾。哈哈哈哈，好笑的梗。但发生的情况是，人们实际上在减速给标语拍照，这显然是不安全的。这有点与标语原本的目的背道而驰。
So they actually told the state, you have to take this down. That is disappointing. I get where they're coming from, though. Right? But earlier this year, the FHWA, they put out their national guidelines for highway safety. They update these every couple of years. And it was a little bit like mom and dad turning on all the lights at a party and telling everybody to go home because they included guidelines for what a highway safety sign should say.
所以他们实际上告诉该州：你们必须把这个撤下来。这真让人失望。不过我能理解他们的出发点。对吧？但今年早些时候，联邦公路管理局发布了国家公路安全指南。他们每隔几年就会更新一次。这有点像爸爸妈妈在派对上打开所有的灯，叫大家回家，因为他们把关于公路安全标语应该写什么的指南也包含进去了。
They said it should be informative. It should be sober. So here it is. This is the FHWA example of a good highway sign. They say unbuckled seat belts equals fine plus points. Oh no, that's dreadful. It's really dry, yeah. So is that it?
他们说标语应该是informative（有信息量的）。应该是sober（严肃理智的）。所以就是这样。这是联邦公路管理局给出的优秀高速公路标语的例子。他们说：未系安全带等于罚款加扣分。哦不，这太糟糕了。真的很枯燥，是的。所以就这样了吗？
Is that the end for the funny highway sign? Well, the guidelines came out in January and suddenly there were all these newspaper stories that were saying like funny signs will be banned, say goodbye to the highway signs. It's actually not quite what's happening here because these are guidelines, right? But Matt says it's really important to him
搞笑高速公路标语就此终结了吗？嗯，指南一月份出台后，突然出现了很多报纸报道，上面写着类似“搞笑标语将被禁”、“跟高速公路标语说再见吧”之类的话。其实这并不是这里真正发生的事情，因为这些只是指南，对吧？但马特说，对他而言，
to keep some humor in the signs because there's evidence of this. There's studies that show this. When you're being entertained, you're more likely to retain these kinds of messages and it makes people think about their driving. So in that way, it does save lives. I don't think we're gonna suddenly see
在标语中保持一些幽默感非常重要，因为有证据表明这一点。有研究显示。当你被娱乐时，你更有可能记住这类信息，这会让人思考他们的驾驶行为。所以从这个角度来看，它确实能挽救生命。我不认为我们突然会看到
a huge swing in fatalities or crashes because of these, but I think we are taking little bites at it and it's worth it. It doesn't cost the taxpayers anything extra and I certainly don't think it makes it worse. So if it makes it better for even a handful of people, then I think it's worth that effort. Now, Roman, if you have an idea for a funny highway sign, I have some good news. You can
因为这些标语而导致交通 fatalities（死亡人数）或 crashes（撞车事故）发生巨大的转变，但我认为我们在一点一点地尝试，这是值得的。它没有花纳税人任何额外的钱，而且我绝对不认为它让情况变得更糟。所以如果它哪怕能让一小部分人的情况变好一点，那么我认为这种努力就是值得的。现在，罗曼，如果你对一个搞笑的高速公路标语有什么点子，我有个好消息。你可以
share your pitches with ODOT. There's a website for it and Matt says they consider every pitch that's sent in. Oh my God. If you enjoy the institution of the funny highway sign, you have an opportunity. It's at the website, zero deaths dot Ohio dot gov. So check it out. I'm going to spend some quality time on this. Well, thank you, Chris.
把你的提案分享给俄亥俄州交通局。有一个专门的网站，马特说他们会认真考虑每一个提交上来的提案。天哪。如果你喜欢搞笑高速公路标语这种形式，你就有机会了。网址是 zerodaths dot ohio dot gov。去看看吧。我要在这上面花点时间好好研究一下。好吧，谢谢你，克里斯。
This is delightful. Thanks, Roman. Okay. So we're here with 99 PI producer Vivian Lay. What do you have for us this year? So I wanted to share a story that was one of the more interesting detours that I stumbled upon while reporting another story. So you remember an episode that we did in early 2024 that's also in contention for the
这太美妙了。谢谢你，罗曼。好的。所以我们现在和99号项目制作人薇薇安·莱（Vivian Lay）在一起。你今年给我们带来了什么？所以我想分享一个故事，这是我在报道另一个故事时偶然发现的一个相当有趣的插曲。所以你还记得我们在2024年初做过的一期节目吗，它也在争夺
longest podcast title ever. It was called warning this podcast contains chemicals known to the state of California to cause cancer or other reproductive harm. Of course. It's one of my favorite titles ever. So it's such a good title. Love it. Yeah.
史上最长播客标题的头衔。它的名字叫：警告：本播客包含加利福尼亚州已知会导致癌症或其他生殖危害的化学物质。当然。这是我最喜欢的标题之一。标题真的太棒了。超爱。是的。
And if other listeners missed that one, it was essentially about the history of this law in California that passed in 1986 that required all California businesses to put a warning label on any products that contain cancer-causing chemicals. And a big part of the reason why that law originally passed was because Jane Fonda was a huge proponent of that proposition. Yes, yeah. I mean, she was the one who kind of rounded up a ton of these celebrities and, you know,
如果其他听众错过了那一期，它基本上是关于加州在1986年通过的一项法律的历史，该法律要求所有加州企业在任何含有致癌化学物质的产品上贴上警告标签。而该法律最初能通过的一个很大原因，是因为简·方达是该提案的超级支持者。是的，是的。我的意思是，她是那种召集了大量名人的家伙，你知道，
they went on this bus. Um... You know? And it actually brought, like, a lot of good attention to this proposition. Yes, exactly. Chiffy Chase was there. It was a whole thing. But while I was researching that story,
他们坐着这辆巴士到处跑。……你知道吗？这确实为这个提案带来了很多积极的关注。是的，exactly（没错）。切维·切斯也在。整个过程挺轰动的。但在我研究那个故事时，
I found out that that victory might not have been possible if it weren't for the Jane Fonda workout tapes. Roman, would you care to hear more? Yes, absolutely, I wanna hear more. Okay, so Jane Fonda has been a huge progressive activist for literally decades. She's probably somewhere getting arrested at a climate rally as we speak. But back in the 1970s, Fonda was this
我发现如果没有简·方达的健身录像带，那次胜利可能根本不会发生。罗曼，你想听听更多细节吗？是的，当然，我想听更多。好的，所以简·方达几十年来一直是个狂热的进步主义活动家。她现在可能正在某个气候集会上被捕，正如我们所说的那样。但早在20世纪70年代，方达是个
huge anti-war activist. And doing that work, she met another fellow anti-war activist turned state assemblyman. His name was Tom Hayden. And Hayden and Fonda eventually got married. And together they realized that they needed to influence politics from within the system. So the mid-ish 1970s, they founded a political action committee called the Campaign for Economic Democracy. And one of the big goals of the CED, I call it the CED for short, was trying to get progressive new left candidates into local office. But the problem was that political action committees take a lot of money to run. This was a statewide organization that made a huge difference in California.
坚定的反战活动家。在从事这项工作时，她遇到了另一位反战活动家转型的州议员。他的名字叫汤姆·海登（Tom Hayden）。海登和方达最终结了婚。他们一起意识到，他们需要从体制内部来影响政治。所以在20世纪70年代中期左右，他们成立了一个名为“争取经济民主运动”的政治行动委员会。CED的核心目标之一——我简称它为CED——是试图将进步的新左翼候选人送入地方公职。但问题是，政治行动委员会的运作需要大量的资金。这是一个在加州产生巨大影响的全州性组织。
This is Jane Fonda in an interview with Democracy Now. We elected people that are still serving in public office in California. And so we had to raise a lot of money because we had a lot of chapters and there was a recession. You see, the CED had to pay for, you know, field offices, staffers put on events, pay for political advertising, all that stuff that helps fund local campaigns. So Fonda was trying to solve this question of how to realistically keep the CED going financially, which was hard because Fonda and Hayden's politics were considered pretty outside of the mainstream at the time. But she says that she got an idea one day after she saw a story about a very controversial politician. I read an article that Lyndon LaRouche, that really bad but very wealthy guy had a computer business that would fund people that would hold those signs at the airports.
这是简·方达在接受《民主现在》采访时说的话。我们选出了至今仍在加州担任公职的人。所以我们必须筹集大量资金，因为我们有很多分支机构，而且当时正值经济衰退。你看，CED必须支付，你知道的，地方办公室、工作人员的费用，举办活动，支付政治广告费用，所有这些帮助资助地方竞选的开销。所以方达一直在试图解决一个问题：如何在财政上现实地让CED维持下去，这很难，因为方达和海登的政治观点在当时被认为是相当边缘化的。但她说她有一天在看到一个关于一个备受争议的政治人物的新闻报道后，有了一个灵感。我读到一篇文章，说林顿·拉鲁什（Lyndon LaRouche）那个真的很坏但非常富有的家伙，有一个电脑业务，可以资助那些在机场举着标语的人。
And I read an article that said that he supported all that with his computer business. So Roman, do you know who Lyndon LaRouche is? I mean, I know the name. Like I kind of know it. I mean, I kind of think of him as this, as I was growing up, this perennial presidential candidate. I know he was referenced on The Simpsons, which is probably why it's stuck in my head. Of course.
我读到一篇文章说他用他的电脑业务资助了这一切。所以罗曼，你知道林顿·拉鲁什是谁吗？我的意思是，我知道这个名字。我算是知道吧。我的意思是，在我成长过程中，我一直把他当成那种常年参选的总统候选人。我知道他在《辛普森一家》里被提到过，这可能就是为什么这个名字留在了我的脑海里。当然。
Yes. But let's say for purposes of this story, like, no, tell me more about Lyndon LaRouche. Okay. So Lyndon LaRouche was a very prolific conspiracy theorist who spouted a lot of terrible anti-Semitic and homophobic and racist views. He also claimed that Queen Elizabeth controlled the world's drug trade. Anyway, so LaRouche is also known for unsuccessfully running for president eight consecutive times in a row.
是的。但为了这个故事的需要，可以说——不，多跟我讲讲林顿·拉鲁什的事。好的。林顿·拉鲁什是一个非常多产的阴谋论者，散布了大量可怕的反犹太主义、恐同和种族主义观点。他还声称英国女王控制了世界的毒品交易。总之，拉鲁什也因为连续八次不间断地参加总统竞选但均告失败而闻名。
He actually holds the record for that. But as you can imagine, Roman running for president even unsuccessfully takes a lot of money. So Fonda read that he was able to fund his political aspirations privately through his computer consulting, software and printing businesses on the side. So I thought, okay, what business can I go into that could make money? And it was the workout. The workout.
他实际上保持着这个记录。但你可以想象，罗曼，竞选总统即使失败也需要大量的资金。所以方达读到新闻，得知他能够通过他的电脑咨询、软件和印刷副业私下资助他的政治雄心。所以我想，好吧，我可以涉足什么业务来赚钱呢？那就是健身。健身。
Wait, so the Jane Fonda workout. Yep. So did the workout exist already? Or workout exist already or did she came first? A little bit of background on the Jane Fonda workout. Exercise is something that had been really important to Jane Fonda for a really long time. But in 1978, around the same time that the CED was getting going, she broke her foot while filming a movie.
等等，所以简·方达健身操。没错。所以这个健身操当时已经存在了吗？或者说健身操当时已经存在，还是她先创立的？关于简·方达健身操的一些背景。锻炼对简·方达来说一直是一件非常重要的事情。但在1978年，就在CED刚开始起步的同期，她在拍电影时摔断了脚。
And she was looking for some new low-impact form of exercise that would be less taxing on that part of the body. And she ended up meeting an exercise instructor named Lenny Kasdan, who introduced her to these long total body workouts, and she fell in love with it. And she ended up opening a bunch of exercise studios and then eventually releasing the Jane Fonda workout book, which was wildly popular. And talk about how much money we're talking about here. You blew everyone away. Tens of millions.
她当时在寻找某种对身体该部位冲击较小的新型低冲击锻炼形式，她最终遇到了一位名叫莱尼·卡斯丹（Lenny Kasdan）的健身教练，他向她介绍了这些长时间的全身锻炼，她深深地爱上了它。她最终开设了一系列健身工作室，然后顺理成章地推出了《简·方达健身操》一书，大受欢迎。我们来谈谈这里涉及的金额。你们把所有人都惊艳到了。数千万。
How long were you on the New York Times bestseller list for? Two years. Two solid years. That is what caused the New York Times to start separating it out into categories, because to have the workout book competing with, you know, Philip Roth or somebody didn't make any sense. I mean, two years on the bestseller list. That's really something.
你在《纽约市报》畅销书排行榜上呆了多久？两年。整整两年。正是这导致《纽约市报》开始将其分门别类，因为让健身书与，你知道的，菲利普·罗斯或其他人的书同台竞争根本说不通。我的意思是，在畅销书排行榜上呆两年。这真的很厉害。
Yeah, it's a lot. How long was the 99PI book on the bestseller list for? On the bestseller list? I mean, it was like in the top 10 for like three weeks. So I was pretty proud of that. That's pretty good. It's still pretty good. But if it wasn't for her splitting out the list, we would not have ranked because we
是的，这很多。99PI的书在畅销书排行榜上呆了多久？在畅销书排行榜上？我的意思是，它大概在前10名呆了三周左右。所以我当时为此挺骄傲的。那相当不错。依然相当不错。但如果不是她把排行榜拆分了，我们根本就排不上号，因为
were on the non-fiction list and not competing with the fiction bestseller list. Interesting. Jane Fonda, thank you again for all of your work. But yeah, so, you know, eventually in the 1980s, like the early 1980s, Fonda was approached to bring her workout to this new fangled technology called home video. And she said that she was at first actually very hesitant to put out a workout tape. You know, she was a movie star at the time and she thought it would be terrible for her acting career. But she agreed to do it because, you
我们是在非虚构类排行榜上，而不是在跟虚构类畅销书排行榜竞争。有趣的是。简·方达，再次感谢你所做的一切。不过是的，所以，你知道，最终在20世纪80年代，比如80年代初，有人找上门来，希望把她的健身操带到一种名为家庭录像的新奇技术上去。她说她一开始其实非常犹豫要不要推出健身录像带。你知道，她当时是个电影明星，她觉得这对她的演艺生涯会是毁灭性的打击。但她最终答应了，因为，
know, a, nobody would ever watch it because this was such a new technology that she barely knew anybody who owned a VCR And B she thought it might bring some extra cash in for the CED and that must have been even more successful Because I didn't even know there was a book, you know, like so like the like me growing up It was the Jane Fonda workout tapes. So it must have even eclipsed those. Oh, yeah, totally She she ended up selling over 17 million tapes And it's actually thought that the Jane Fonda workout tapes were so popular that they led to an increase in VCR
你知道的，a，根本没人会看，因为这是一项太新的技术，她几乎不认识谁家有VCR；b，她觉得这或许能为CED带来一些额外的现金。而且这个肯定更成功，因为我甚至都不知道还有一本书，你知道，就好像——像我这样的人成长过程中，接触的都是简·方达健身录像带。所以它的影响力一定甚至超越了那本书。哦，是的，完全超越了。她最终卖出了超过1700万盘录像带。
sales. And Fonda says that pretty much all of that money went straight into the campaign for economic democracy. Wow. Well, that's incredible. I mean, in addition to like pushing VCR sales, did the tape sales actually move forward the politics of the CED? Did it actually change California or world politics? Yeah. So the CED invested in a bunch of progressive causes in California, like investing in solar power, labor rights, anti-war initiatives, women's rights, of course, proposition 65.
人们甚至认为，简·方达健身录像带太受欢迎了，以至于它们直接推动了VCR销量的增长。方达说，几乎所有的这些钱都直接流向了争取经济民主运动。哇。嗯，这太不可思议了。我的意思是，除了推动VCR销量之外，录像带的销售真的推动了CED的政治主张吗？它真的改变了加州或世界的政治吗？是的。所以CED在加州的许多进步事业上进行了投资，比如投资太阳能、劳工权益、反战倡议、妇女权益，当然还有第65号提案。
But I think one of the biggest, most tangible successes of the CED was getting rent control laws passed in Santa Monica. And this is something that has actually had a lasting impact on the city and it still exists today. Wow. So if you live in a rent controlled apartment in the city of Santa Monica, this is essentially because of Jane Fonda and the Jane Fonda workout tapes. Wow.
但我认为CED最大、最切实的成功之一，是在圣莫尼卡推动通过了 rent control（租金管制）法律。而这确实对这座城市产生了持久的影响，至今仍然存在。哇。所以如果你住在圣莫尼卡市的一套受租金管制的公寓里，这基本上都要归功于简·方达和简·方达健身录像带。哇。
Yes, exactly. And I actually do have a friend who lived in a rent controlled apartment in Santa Monica for like 14 years and he only just recently moved out to start a family. And when I learned about this, I texted him and I was just like, Brandon, if you ever meet Jane Fonda, you better thank her for saving you thousands and thousands of dollars. That's perfect. Oh, it's such a fun little side story. I'm glad we could take this little detour as a little bonus from your Prop 65 story, which people should go listen to if
是的，完全如此。而且我确实有个朋友在圣莫尼卡的租金管制公寓里住了大约14年，他最近才刚搬出去组建家庭。当我了解到这一点时，我给发信息说：布兰登，如果你哪天遇到简·方达，你最好好好谢谢她为你省下了成千上万美元。太完美了。哦，这真是一个有趣的小插曲。我很高兴我们能把这段小插曲当作你第65号提案故事的一个小彩蛋，大家如果没有听过的话应该去听听。它简直是我近期记忆中最喜欢的节目之一。谢谢。太棒了。祝我圣诞快乐。谢谢你，薇薇安。谢谢你，罗曼。接下来，为什么信仰万物皆有完美版本的古希腊人会痴迷于双脚。以及那个发明了炸药的人是如何死而复生的——某种程度上——来洗清他的
they haven't heard it. It's like one of my favorites from recent memories. Thank you. Awesome. Merry Christmas to me. Thank you, Vivian. Thank you, Roman. Coming up, why the ancient Greeks who believed in a perfect version of everything were obsessed with feet. And how the man who invented dynamite came back from the dead, sort of, to clear his
名声，并最终创立了世界上最著名的奖项。广告之后继续。在十月份，我们发布了一期节目，邀请了伟大的斯蒂芬·约翰逊（Steven Johnson），谈论他的最新著作《地狱机器》，全书讲述了炸药的发明如何彻底改变了美国的政治格局，当它成为国内恐怖分子首选的武器时。炸药释放了一种前所未有的、恐怖的、暴力的破坏力量，这是世界从未见过的。
name and ended up creating the most famous prize in the world. That's after the break. In October, we released an episode with the great Steven Johnson, talking about his latest book, The Infernal Machine, all about how the invention of dynamite drastically changed the political landscape in the US when it became the weapon of choice by domestic terrorists. Dynamite unleashed a new kind of horrific, violent, destructive power that the world had never seen before.
也就是人们被炸得粉身碎骨。就像对身体的物理损害，所有这些报纸报道都说：我们无法辨认这具遗体残骸。如果你正好处于炸药爆炸的中心，你知道的，你就会被炸成人类血肉的小碎片。这在以前并没有真正在人体上发生过。而它突然开始一直发生。炸药是由阿尔弗雷德·诺贝尔发明的，这让他成为世界上最富有的人之一，但正是经历了一场家庭悲剧和一个身份错认事件，
Which was people being fully blown up. Like the physical damage to the body, there's all this kind of newspaper reports like we were not able to identify the remains of this other person. Like if you were right on top of a dynamite explosion, you know, you were reduced to small little pieces of human flesh. And that was something that had not really happened to the human body before. And it suddenly started happening all the time. Dynamite was invented by Alfred Nobel and it made him one of the richest men in the world, but it took a death in the family and a case of mistaken identity
他才真正理解了公众对他的真正看法。作家斯蒂芬·约翰逊向我讲述了这个神奇的故事。他的兄弟去世了，几家法国报纸搞混了，以为诺贝尔本人死了。所以他处于一个有点不同寻常的境地，可以在报纸上阅读自己的讣告，而且这些讣告并不积极。其中最著名的标题是：死亡商人死了。
for him to truly understand what the public really thought of him. Author Stephen Johnson talked me through this amazing story. His brother died and a couple of French newspapers got confused and thought that Nobel himself had died. So he was put in the somewhat unusual position of getting to read his own obituaries in the paper and they were not positive. And the kind of the famous headline was, the merchant of death is dead.
是的，而且情况更糟，因为他的讣告的第一行写着：阿尔弗雷德·诺贝尔博士，通过找到比以往任何时候都更快杀死更多人的方法而变得富有，昨天去世了。这真是一个沉重的打击。是的，是的。你肯定不想读到这个。如果你还活着的话。所以，你知道，他毕生都在致力于——你知道，向世界释放这种爆炸性的
Yeah, and it gets worse because the first line of his obituary reads, Dr. Alfred Nobel, who became rich by finding ways to kill more people faster than ever before, died yesterday. Which is a real gut punch. Yeah, yeah. You'd hate to read that. If you're still alive. And so, you know, this whole career that he'd spent, you know, unleashing this explosive
力量，旨在帮助其现代化、建设铁路、摩天大楼、地铁和下水道系统，所有这些都已经实现，并使他成为世界上最富有的人之一。在他所谓的“死亡”之时，人们记住的是，他向世界释放了所有这些可怕的、灾难性的暴力，
force on the world designed to help it modernize and build railroads and skyscrapers and subways and sewer systems, all of which had happened and which had made him one of the wealthiest people in the world. At his alleged death, what was remembered was that he had unleashed all this terrible, catastrophic violence on the world
这都要归功于那些偷走他的技术并将其用于邪恶用途的政治激进分子。但今天人们绝对不是这样记住他的，这一切都要归功于一个人。所以在此之前，诺贝尔与一位名叫贝尔塔·冯·苏特纳（Bertha von Suttner）的和平活动家建立了长久深厚的友谊。她曾向他辩论，认为他应该将自己庞大的财富用于当时正在兴起的和平事业。而在偶然阅读自己讣告的过程中发生的一些事情，以及他意识到自己的传奇很可能会被严重玷污，
thanks to the political radicals who had stolen his technology and put it to nefarious uses. But that is definitely not how he is remembered today, because of one person. And so Nobel had developed, before this point, a long enduring friendship with a peace activist named Bertha von Sutner. And she had argued to him that he should use his prodigious fortune in the service of the peace cause that was kind of on the rise at that point. And something in the accidental reading of his obituaries and the recognition that his legacy was likely to be very tarnished,
加上他与苏特纳的长谈，促使他修改了遗嘱，将绝大部分财富用来资助如今与诺贝尔的名字联系最紧密的事物——不是炸药，而是诺贝尔奖，其中最著名的就是和平奖。这非常不寻常，科学类的奖项是一回事，物理学和化学的诺贝尔奖似乎说得通，特别是对于化学这种诺贝尔本人曾是先驱的领域更是如此。但和平奖的概念是非常不寻常的，而它现在可以说是世界上一个人所能获得的最高声望的奖项。冯·苏特纳实际上也是该奖项的早期获得者之一。
and his long conversation with Suttner led him to change his will and take the vast majority of his fortune to endow now the thing that is actually most associated with Nobel's name, not dynamite, but the Nobel prizes and most famously the Peace Prize, which was a very unusual, it was one thing to have a kind of a scientific prize, a Nobel Prize in physics and chemistry seemed to make sense and particularly made sense with something like chemistry where Nobel had been a pioneer in chemistry himself. But the idea of a Peace Prize was a very unusual thing, and it is now arguably like the most prestigious prize that one can receive in the world. And von Suttner actually was one of the early recipients of it.
所以她的传奇的一部分就是倡导和平，同时也倡导诺贝尔设立和平奖，这在许多方面成为了世界上一股向善的力量，并延续至今。斯蒂芬·约翰逊的最新著作名为《地狱机器》。我很喜欢，你们也会喜欢的，它简直太棒了（dynamite），正如他关于科学、技术和创新的其他13本书一样，
So part of her legacy was advocating for peace and also advocating for Nobel to create the Peace Prize, which then became a force for good in the world in many ways and enduring to this day. Steven Johnson's most recent book is called The Infernal Machine. I loved it, you're gonna love it, it's dynamite, as are his other 13 books about science, technology and innovation,
尽管其他几本其实不是关于炸药的。只有这本是，但它们依然同样精彩。那么，乔·罗斯伯格（Joe Rosenberg），你今天给我带来了什么？嗯，罗曼，这个故事开始于几个月前，当时我在家里赤脚走来走去，我走进室友的房间想问她点事。还没等我开口，她就脱口而出：“哦天哪，你的脚到底怎么回事？”我低头看了看自己的脚，然后又抬起头，
even though the others are not actually about dynamite. Only this one is, but they're all dynamite nonetheless. So Joe Rosenberg, what do you have for me today? Well, Roman, this story starts just a couple months ago when I'm at home and I'm walking around barefoot and I go into my roommate's room to ask her about something. And before I can even get a word in, she just blurts out, Oh my God, what the hell is wrong with your feet? And I look down at my feet, I look up again,
我说：“你什么意思？”因为她听起来真的很惊慌。接着她说道：“你的大脚趾比第二个脚趾短。”是的，确实如此。我的大脚趾比第二个脚趾稍微短一点。但说实话，在这之前，我从来没有想过人们大脚趾相对于其他脚趾的长度问题，更不用说我自己的了。你知道，经你这么一说，我的第二个脚趾也比大脚趾长，但如果你让我画一只脚，我想我会把它们画成从大脚趾到小脚趾呈某种直线斜向排列的渐进形态。哦，好吧，所以你的大脚趾也比第二个脚趾短。
and I say, what do you mean? Because she sounded truly alarmed. At which point she goes, your big toe is shorter than your second toe. Yeah, and it's true. My big toe is slightly shorter than my second toe. But genuinely, before this moment, it had never once occurred to me
没错，没错。我是你们的一员。哦，好吧，那这，好吧，那么，事实上，这个故事将有一个——突然之间，事情的赌注变得高得多了。好的。所以大多数脚，你知道的，是的，或多或少呈现出那种大脚趾最大的斜线。而我的脚，显然还有你的脚，并不是这样的。至少在我的情况下，我的脚尖反而只是形成了一种柔和的曲线。但我的室友对此非常坚持，认为我大脚趾的长度，或者具体来说是它们缺乏长度，简直是大错特错。
to think about the lengths of people's big toes relative to their other toes, much less my own. You know, now that you mention it, my second toe is also longer than my big toe, but if you were to tell me to draw a foot, I think I would draw them in sort of a kind of straight diagonal progression from big toe to little toe. Oh, okay, so your big toe is also shorter
所以你是如何接受这一点的，在情绪上？表面上，表现得优雅。好的。内心深处，我整个人都要崩溃了。我身上已经有其他让我不满意的地方了。所以我做了我当时唯一能做的事，那就是冲回
than your second toe. That's right, that's right. I'm one of you. Oh, okay, well this is, okay, well then, in fact, this story is gonna have, suddenly the stakes just got a lot higher. Okay. So most feet, you know, yeah, they form more or less
我身上已经有其他让我不满意的地方了。所以我做了我当时唯一能做的事，那就是冲回房间，打开电脑，查一下大脚趾异常短意味着什么。你查到了什么？我的意思是，互联网对你说了什么？并不是说我在身体出现状况时对互联网深信不疑。但话虽如此，互联网到底对你说了什么？好吧，在这种情况下，你应该对互联网深信不疑，因为我找到了彻底的平反。哦，太棒了。
that kind of diagonal line with the big toe being biggest. And my feet, and apparently your feet, do not. At least in my case, the end of my foot instead just kind of forms this gentle curve. But my roommate was just adamant about this, that the length of my big toes, or specifically their lack of length, was just plain wrong.
那种大脚趾最长、呈对角线形状的脚。而我的脚，显然还有你的脚，并不是这样的。至少在我的情况里，我的脚尖只是形成了一种平缓的弧度。但我的室友对此非常坚持，认为我大脚趾的长度，或者具体来说是它们的短小，简直是大错特错。
And so how did you take this in, like, emotionally? Externally, with grace. Okay. Internally, I am freaking out. I already have other things about my body that I'm not pleased with. And so I do the only thing I can do at that moment, which is to rush back I already have other things about my body that I'm not pleased with. And so I do the only thing I can do at that moment, which is to rush back to my room,
那你当时在情感上是怎么接受这件事的？表面上，我表现得很优雅。好吧。内心里，我快要崩溃了。我本来就对身体的其他一些地方不太满意。所以我做了当时唯一能做的事，那就是冲回我本来就对身体的其他一些地方不太满意。所以我做了当时唯一能做的事，那就是冲回我的房间，
go on my computer, and look up what it means when your big toe is abnormally short. What did you find? I mean, what did the internet tell you? Not that I put a ton of credence on the internet when it comes to like what thing is going on with my body. But still, what did the internet tell you? Well, in this case, you should put total credence in the internet because I found total vindication. Oh, excellent.
打开电脑，搜索大脚趾异常短是什么意思。你找到了什么？我是说，互联网对你说了什么？倒不是说我有多信任互联网，尤其是关于我身体出了什么状况的时候。不过话说回来，互联网对你说了什么？嗯，在这种情况，你完全可以相信互联网，因为我找到了全方位的平反。噢，太棒了。
Yeah, it turns out that this is a thing in the art world because in the Western artistic tradition, throughout its long history of depicting the human form, there are three major foot shapes that you'll see come up. And they are Egyptian, Roman, and Greek. And so I'm assuming that's because this is how the Egyptian, Romans, and Greek, like sculptors and painters each portrayed feet. Exactly.
是的，原来这在艺术界是真实存在的，因为在西方艺术传统中，在其描绘人体形态的漫长历史中，你会看到三种主要的脚型反复出现。它们分别是埃及脚、罗马脚和希腊脚。所以我想这是因为古代的埃及人、罗马人和希腊人，比如雕塑家和画家，都是这样描绘脚的。没错。
But also, each of these three categories corresponds to types of feet commonly found worldwide. And broadly speaking, an Egyptian foot is when your big toe is longer than your other toes. And that is far and away, as mentioned, you know, the most common type of foot worldwide. In one study, it's something like 70% of the global population. Then there is the slightly rare Roman foot, that is when your big toe is the same length as your second toe and often third toe. And that's like 25% of people. And then there is what you and I have, the Greek foot, which is when your big toe is shorter than your second toe.
但同时，这三种脚型中的每一种都对应着世界各地常见的一些脚型。大体来说，埃及脚是指你的大脚趾比其他脚趾长。如前所述，这远远是世界上最常见的一种脚型。在一项研究中，它大约占全球人口的70%。然后是稍微罕见的罗马脚，那是你的大脚趾和第二脚趾（通常还有第三脚趾）长度相同。这大约占人们的25%。最后就是你和我拥有的这种——希腊脚，也就是你的大脚趾比第二脚趾短。
And the Greek foot is the rarest foot of all. In this same study, only 5% of people have it. Wow, I would have never thought such a thing. So given that it's so rare, what determines whether or not you have a Greek foot? It's a little unclear. You'll be shocked to learn that toe length is not a top priority in the medical community right now.
而希腊脚是所有脚型中最罕见的。在同一项研究中，只有5%的人拥有这种脚。哇，我从来没想过会有这种事。既然它这么罕见，那么是什么决定了你有没有希腊脚呢？目前还有点不清楚。你可能会大吃一惊，脚趾长度现在并不是医学界最优先关注的问题。
And to be clear, there's no definitive study of the numbers. They can vary quite a bit. But it pops up more in a few populations throughout the world. So according to, again, different studies, maybe like 30% of the Ndoma in Nigeria have it. Possibly a majority of people with Ainu ancestry in northern Japan have it as well. But the important part for you and me is that according to no lesser
需要说明的是，并没有关于这些数字的决定性研究。它们可能会有相当大的变化。但它在世界上的某些人群中出现得更多。因此，根据不同的研究，尼日利亚的恩多马人大约有30%的人拥有这种脚。日本北部阿伊努血统的人中，可能也有大多数人拥有这种脚。但对你我而言重要的地方在于，根据绝不逊于……的来源
source than Wikipedia, my foot, my much maligned and ridiculed foot with its short big toe was not only depicted, but treasured by the ancient Greeks who believed, and I kid you not, that it was the platonically ideal form of the human foot. Right. Well, take that unnamed roommate. That'll show her making fun of Joe Rosenberg's feet. That's right. And I'm obviously, I'm not going to disclose her name. I'd hate to humiliate her in front of our audience. That's embarrassing. Yeah.
维基百科的权威来源，我的脚，我那饱受诟病和嘲笑、长着短大脚趾的脚，不仅被古希腊人所描绘，而且被他们视若珍宝。他们甚至——我可没开玩笑——认为这是柏拉图理念中完美的人体脚型。没错。好吧，记住了，那个不知名的室友。这下看她以后怎么好意思取笑乔·罗森伯格的脚。没错。显然，我不会透露她的名字。我可不想在我们的听众面前羞辱她。那太尴尬了。是的。
Yeah, and it gets better because it says that throughout most of Western artistic history, it was, quote, an idealized form which has persisted as an aesthetic standard. So like you and I have won like the foot lottery. The Western canon has determined that we have beautiful beautiful feet We do and I need to insert a brief PSA here, okay, which is that in the medical world? There's actually a name for it. It's called Morton's toe
对，而且情况还不止于此，因为上面说在大多数西方艺术史中，它被称为“一种理想化的形式，并作为一种美学标准延续了下来”。所以，你我都好像中了脚部彩票一样。西方正统审美已经认定我们拥有美丽至极的脚。确实如此，我这里需要插播一个简短的公益广告，好吧，那就是在医学界，其实对这种脚型有个名字，叫做莫顿趾。
Okay, and it can lead to gait issues that lead to leg and back pain later on in life So, you know if you feel like you have an extreme version of this maybe go check it out with your doctor But that is not relevant to what we're discussing today. We're going to move on to the more important stuff here. Okay, so how did that aesthetic idea come about? How did the Greek foot initially become considered this, you know, the quote unquote, persistent aesthetic standard? Well, perhaps not surprisingly, something like 40% of Greeks have it and possibly, yeah,
好吧，它可能会导致步态问题，并在晚年引起腿部和背部疼痛，所以，如果你觉得自己有这种脚型的极端版本，也许可以去咨询一下你的医生。但这跟我们今天讨论的内容无关。我们要继续讨论更重要的事情。好吧，那么这种美学理念是怎么产生的呢？希腊脚最初是怎么被认为具有这种所谓的“持久美学标准”的呢？好吧，也许并不令人意外，大约40%的希腊人都有这种脚型，而且可能，是的……
like a majority of Greeks have it and possibly, yeah, like a majority of Greek men. So the ancient Greeks just looked down on their feet and just decided, oh, this toe configuration is the best. Obviously. Yeah. Right. And if you think back to your high school history class, you might remember that when
就像大多数希腊人都有这种脚型，可能，是的，就像大多数希腊男性都有一样。所以古希腊人只是低头看了看自己的脚，就决定了，“哦，这种脚趾结构是最好的”。理所当然。没错。如果你回想一下高中的历史课，你可能还记得当……时
classical Greek culture came about, the Greek philosophers and artists were just obsessed with the idea that you could find the ideal form of every little thing. Right. The Greeks thought they could deduce this idealized form of the perfect tree. The Platonic ideal is what I was taught. Yes, exactly. And there was actually a famous Greek sculptor, Polykleitos, who apparently laid out the perfect proportions of a human male body in a treatise. And sadly, all the exact measurements from this treatise are lost to history.
古典希腊文化兴起时，希腊哲学家和艺术家沉迷于这样一种理念：你可以找到每一件小事物的理想形态。没错。希腊人认为他们可以推演出完美树木的这种理想形态。我学过的一个概念就是柏拉图式的理念。是的，完全正确。当时有一位著名的希腊雕塑家波留克列特斯，他显然在一篇论文中阐述了男性人体雕塑的完美比例。遗憾的是，这篇论文中的精确测量数据已经随着历史失传了。
But one thing that Polykleitos and the other Greek artists believed was that the big toe absolutely had to be shorter than the second toe. And how much shorter are we talking here? Admittedly, it's a little unclear, and it's also honestly not clear what their rationale was besides the fact that so many Greek people had it.
但波留克列特斯和其他希腊艺术家坚信的一点是，大脚趾绝对必须比第二脚趾短。我们这里说的是短多少呢？老实说，这有点说不清楚，而且老实说，除了许多希腊人都有这种脚型之外，他们的基本逻辑是什么也不太清楚。
Every article I've found on this likes to say it might have been due to the golden ratio, but what exactly toe length has to do with the golden ratio, no one ever bothers to explain. Yeah, as soon as the golden ratio is brought into something, I'm like, okay, this is a bunch of nonsense. Yeah, nevertheless, the Greeks end up having a disproportionate cultural impact.
我找到的每一篇关于这个的文章都喜欢说，这可能是由于黄金比例，但脚趾长度到底跟黄金比例有什么关系，从来没有人费心去解释过。是的，一旦把黄金比例扯进某个东西里，我就觉得，好吧，这完全是一堆无稽之谈。是的，尽管如此，希腊人最终还是产生了不成比例的文化影响力。
And so there's basically been like 2,500 years of Western art in which the depiction of the human form has been influenced by the Greeks. And so when it comes to the great works of Western art, Artaud's Roman are in very good company. Needless to say, I prepared a small slideshow. Let me start you off with what is arguably the most admired and well-preserved ancient Greek bronze of all time.
因此，在西方艺术史上有大约2500年的时间，人体形态的描绘都受到了希腊人的影响。所以当谈到西方艺术的伟大杰作时，罗马脚（译者注：原文Artaud's Roman可能为语音误识别，实际指Roman feet）也是不遑多让的。不用说，我准备了一个小幻灯片。让我先向大家展示可以说是史上最受赞赏、保存最完好的古希腊青铜雕塑。
It's called Boxer at Rest, in which this very handsome guy, who I personally think kind of looks like Paul Mescal, sits in this kind of beautiful, exhausted repose. Okay, let me click on this one. Okay. Oh yeah, yeah, that's nice. And here is a detail, of course, of one of his perfect Greek feet with its slightly smaller big toe.
它被称为《休息中的拳击手》，在这座雕塑中，这个非常英俊的家伙——我个人觉得他长得有点像保罗·麦斯卡——以一种美丽、疲惫的姿态坐着。好吧，让我点击一下这个。好的。哦，对，对，真不错。当然，这里有他的完美希腊脚的细节特写，大脚趾稍微小一点。
Yeah, this is very subtle, but I can see this is a lovely idealized foot. Absolutely. And lest you think this is restricted to men, let's move on to Renaissance painting with no less than Botticelli's Birth of Venus. Oh yeah. Venus, I will remind you, is the goddess of Roman beauty. And here are her even more pronounced Greek feet.
是的，这非常微妙，但我能看出这是一只可爱且理想化的脚。绝对的。为了让你们觉得这不仅限于男性，让我们转向文艺复兴时期的绘画，看看波提切利的《维纳斯的诞生》。哦，对。我提醒大家，维纳斯是罗马美神。这里是她更加显著的希腊脚。
Oh goodness, yeah, they really are leaning in hard. It looks like a finger almost. Yeah, and the list of Greek feet goes on. You know, Leonardo's drawings of the ideal human form, you know, the one in the circle. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. Michelangelo's David, and my personal favorite example of Greek feet,
哦天哪，是的，他们真的是在极力表现这一点。看起来简直像根手指。是的，希腊脚的例子还有很多。你知道，达芬奇对理想人体形态的画作，你知道，那个在圆圈里的。哦对，对，对。米开朗基罗的《大卫》，还有我个人最喜欢的希腊脚例子……
the Statue of Liberty. Oh wow, yeah, I've never noticed this before. Is that like the biggest short big toe on display in the world? It might be. I, you know, there's only a few challengers Is that like the biggest short big toe on display in the world? It might be. I, you know, I, there's only a few challengers and I probably should check them out.
自由女神像。哦哇，是的，我以前从来没注意到这个。那是世界上展出的最大的“短大脚趾”吗？它可能真是。我，你知道，只有少数几个挑战者……那是世界上展出的最大的“短大脚趾”吗？它可能真是。我，你知道，我，只有少数几个挑战者，我大概应该去查证一下。
I've never looked at her feet before. Like not only is the second toe quite long, the pinky toe is weirdly far back. It looks bizarre. Yeah, no, it is truly bizarre looking. I personally think that my Greek feet are better than her Greek feet. And I should add, I think we also might actually make
我以前从来没看过她的脚。不仅第二脚趾相当长，小脚趾也离奇地靠后。看起来太诡异了。对，不，它看起来确实很诡异。我个人觉得我的希腊脚比她的希腊脚更好看。我还要补充的是，我觉得我们俩其实也可以……
great foot models if we ever needed the extra cash. Because I can't confirm this, but a quick Google search for foot related products like sandals suggests that a disproportionate number of foot models also have Greek feet. So I think the modeling agencies might need to give us a call. Yeah, I think that makes total sense to me.
如果我们需要一些外快的话，我们绝对能成为很棒的脚模。因为我无法证实这一点，但快速在谷歌上搜索一下凉鞋等与脚相关的产品就会发现，不成比例的大量脚模也拥有希腊脚。所以我觉得模特公司可能应该给我们打个电话。是的，我觉得这完全说得通。
This is opening up a dark doorway. Yeah, I mean, do you know about wiki feet, Roman? I do, I mean, I heard that name before, but I've never dared to look. I do know that at one point, I posted a picture on Instagram of a piece of art in my house and we don't wear shoes in my house and so my feet were on display and my stepdaughter texted and
这打开了一扇黑暗的大门。是的，我的意思是，罗马，你知道维基脚网（WikiFeet）吗？我知道，我的意思是，我以前听过这个名字，但我从来不敢去看。我确实知道，有一次我在Instagram上发布了一张我家一件艺术品的照片，我们家里是不穿鞋的，所以我的脚露出来了，然后我继女发信息说……
said, you put your feet on the internet? And I was like, what? So I'm aware of this, but I have not opened that door. Like this is not a subculture. I'm like going to explore greatly, I don't think. Well, but at least you know now that you have truly beautiful feet. Well, you have beautiful feet too, Joe. Oh my God, thank you, Roman.
“你把你的脚发到网上了？”然后我说，“什么？”所以我知道这回事，但我没有打开那扇门。这可不是我要深入探索的亚文化，我想不会。不过，至少你现在知道你确实拥有一双美丽的脚。好吧，你也有美丽的脚，乔。天哪，谢谢你，罗马。
Yeah, don't hate us because we're beautiful. Don't hate us because we're beautiful. Thank you so much, Joe. This was fun. This was a lot of fun, Roman. Thanks. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Barupe, Vivian Ley, Jacob Medina-Gleason, and Joe Rosenberg. Edited by Christopher Johnson, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Fact checking by Laura Bullant. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our
对，不要因为我们长得好看而恨我们。不要因为我们长得好看而恨我们。非常感谢你，乔。这很有趣。这真的很有趣，罗马。谢谢。《99%隐形》本周由克里斯·巴鲁普、维维安·莱、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森和乔·罗森伯格制作。由克里斯托弗·约翰逊剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔提供。劳拉·布兰特负责事实核查。凯茜·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，德兰尼·霍尔是我们的……
senior editor. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Lashma Don, Nina Potok, Kelly Prime, Jason DeLeon, and me, Roman Mars. Taylor Shedrick is our intern. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stephen Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find us on blue sky, which is definitely the best mass social media
高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、拉什马·唐、尼娜·波托克、凯利·普莱姆、杰森·德莱昂，还有我，罗马·马尔斯。泰勒·谢德里克是我们的实习生。99%隐形标志由斯蒂芬·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一员，现在总部位于奥克兰美丽的住宅区上城潘多拉大楼向北六个街区。你可以在蓝天（Blue Sky）找到我们，它绝对是目前每个人都可以参与的最好的大众社交媒体……
site that anyone can hang out on. We're going to make a go of it there. So give it a try, or you can connect with us on our discord server where there's over 5,000 people talking about the power broker and talking about architecture, talking about bunch of other stuff. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们打算在那里大展身手。所以去试试吧，或者你也可以在我们的Discord服务器上与我们联系，那里有5000多人在讨论《权力的经纪人》、建筑以及其他一堆事情。那里有通往99PI每一集往期节目的链接，网址是99PI.org。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。